(mellow music)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing Show,
the podcast for growing and scaling
your business with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell
and we are so fired up you're here.
This show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content noticed
and the latest money-making strategies
working right now online.
So, whether you wanna
grow your YouTube channel
or maximize online video
across social media,
this is for you.
And on today's episode,
we're gonna talk about
the vision, the heart, and what to expect
from the Think Marketing Show.
But first, who are we?
- Man, I'm fired up, Heather, to be here.
This is the foundational episode.
And yeah, let's talk
about first who we are
and why we're even doin' this podcast.
- Yes, so Sean, Sean Cannell,
you are a college dropout,
small town kid, starting
making videos in your bedroom
and a decade later, now, you've built
a multiple seven figure, or
multi-million dollar business,
media company with over
100 million video views.
Congratulations--
- Hey, appreciate it.
- 1.5 million subscribers on YouTube.
Not even that, you've also done
multiple six figures in the event space,
multiple six figures in
speaking and coaching,
multiple six figures in brand deals
working with brands like
Canon and Amazon and Sony,
and also seven figures
in affiliate marketing
and seven figures in digital products.
Can we clap it up?
Great job, Sean.
- I mean, that was,
that was a lot of flexing there,
but I guess the reason we
kinda wanted to share that
was because that's the
heart behind this podcast
is, having been in this for a decade,
having been making so many mistakes
and also having had a lotta successes
and so, that's what we wanna share,
is all of these tips that we've learned
in the trenches, building this stuff.
But then, of course, I'm
here with Heather Torres,
the host of the Think Marketing Show
and for people that are just meeting you,
you're a multi-passionate entrepreneur,
you've done all kinds of things.
You've done social media for,
like, Washington State Parks,
you've done fitness studios
and brick and mortar businesses
and you've helped scale businesses
with marketing and paid advertising
and you're also the Chief
Operation Officer of Think Media,
you've helped build the team here,
a leader, teamwork and operations.
And those are some of the topics, right?
That's the essence of Think Marketing,
is the behind the scenes stuff
for building your business.
You're also a content creator on YouTube,
helping moms with your
own YouTube channel,
one of the content
creators on Think Media,
which is our main tech channel,
and you're doing a
lotta other cool things.
One of your biggest passions
is productivity and time management,
which is something we
all need as entrepreneurs
because it's hard to stay on top of
all of this marketing stuff plus
the business-building stuff
plus life plus business.
And so, you've got all kinds of strategies
to help purpose-driven entrepreneurs
maximize their time so
they can get more done.
- Yeah, that did sound like a lotta
flexing, but I'm proud of it.
I think we have a lot
to give and, you know,
part of the reason we wanted
to do this, like you said,
was because over the decade
that you've been working
and I've been working in this space,
we have done a lotta things wrong
and we've had a lotta struggles,
but we've done things right
and we wanna help you
shorten that learning curve.
So, that's part of the reason
why we wanted to make this show.
- Yeah, and there's something about
trying to find simplicity.
Some of the topics we'll dive
into are complex in nature
but we wanna simplify marketing in general
because marketing isn't
even the main focus
of so many business owners,
but it's something you have to do.
We say, "You gotta date SAM."
"Who's SAM?"
We're actually both, by the way,
married to different people.
- Other people.
- And just as a foundational thing.
People see us in videos
together and whatnot.
I'm married to my wife,
Sonja Cannell and you?
- I'm married to my wonderful
husband, Isaiah Torres
- And both of us, though, think
we both still need to date SAM.
And what's SAM?
Sales and marketing.
Like, if you wanna keep
your business going,
you gotta master sales,
you gotta master marketing.
But those topics can be kinda complex,
so we wanna simplify those.
And then also, we unify,
here on this podcast,
around some of our core values.
I mean, for us, that's faith,
that's family, that's legacy.
And you know, Heather,
marketing kinda has a bad rap
and there's different flavors
of marketing out there.
Marketing's even one of those topics
that can rub people the wrong way because
it's maybe known for being
shady or being forceful.
And we really believe, though,
that marketing is so important
and that marketing changes
lives when done right
and that we can ultimately build
high-impact and high-profit
businesses that not just
impact people but can change
the world through marketing.
- Yeah, and for us, it really is
about building relationships.
Building relationships with people who are
wanting the same things
that we are building, right?
Building those lifestyle-type businesses
and helping people
understand that you can have
an online and an offline business,
but using the power of
online video is really
the vehicle.
- Absolutely.
And of course, you know, what topics
can you expect from this show?
Well, as the author of YouTube Secrets
and as, maybe if you're
new to, if you've already
known me for awhile, YouTube
is certainly a major theme
and that's gonna be a
major theme of the show.
Video marketing in general.
I mean, we're so passionate
about video marketing
on LinkedIn, on Instagram,
what's happening on TikTok
and emerging platforms,
on Facebook, on Twitter.
And then, of course,
paid video advertising.
But there's so much that
goes on behind the business.
Like, what's the point of
this Think Marketing Show?
'Cause we have Think
Media, I've got my channel
that I do with Benji,
called Video Influencers.
But we realized that where
are we talkin' about, like,
email marketing, where are
we talking about, like,
the blocks where we build
websites and you build pages,
and what are some of the
other topics, Heather?
- Yeah, I'm really
excited to go deeper into
creating and selling digital courses.
You know, digital courses
is what allowed, Sean,
your family and my family
to really have freedom
and we wanna share how you do
it here on Think Marketing.
Also, things like advanced
strategies for using YouTube
so that you can build your business
and your brand on your own terms.
It's so important to us
that you see, you know,
that icebreaker or that iceberg,
it's what's below the water that
we wanna share here on
the Think Marketing Show.
- Yeah, we'll be talkin'
about software tools
and just all of those kinds of elements
so that you can actually
build a real business
on the other side of your social media
and your video marketing efforts.
So, where can you find us?
Well, wherever you're
listening to this right now,
you can, of course, subscribe right here,
but the Think Marketing Show is gonna be
on Apple Podcasts, it's
gonna be on YouTube,
it's gonna be on Spotify, SoundCloud.
Wherever you consume your
audio or your video content,
we're gonna be there, so make sure to hit
that subscribe button so
you don't miss an episode.
- Yeah and if you are on Apple right now,
we'd love for you to leave a review
and let us know what you
think of this first episode
and let us know what type of
topics you'd like us to cover.
And you can also reach us on
Instagram.
- That's right.
And so, if you actually wanna
get involved, a couple things.
Number one, make sure you
subscribe, so that way
you start getting these
episodes as they're released.
And number two, send us a message.
You can tag us on
Instagram stories or DM us.
@seancannell, Sean Cannell
rhymes with channell,
first name Sean S-E-A-N,
last name Cannell, C-A-N-N-E-L-L.
There's no way, just in
audio, that you woulda been
able to figure that out, so I'm sorry
to have hit you with
that, but it's essential.
So, tag me on Instagram or Heather Torres,
which is @mrs, M-R-S, mrsheather,
as Heather would be spelled,
H-E-A-T-H-E-R-T-O-R-R-E-S.
Sorry to have burdened you with that,
but we wanna connect
on Instagram, so DM us,
tag us on stories so we can hear that
you're listening to the
podcast, that you're connecting,
and then when you're subscribed.
And the cool thing is,
is that the first episode
is already out on all these platforms.
So, what can they do next?
- Well, I'd say go watch
that episode over on YouTube
or go to the next episode here
in your podcast app.
- Yeah, man.
We are fired up.
Thank you so much for
being here at the genesis,
the ground floor, the inception,
the very bedrock of the
Think Marketing Show.
We are fired up and we
think that you're gonna get
so much value outta this content
that's truly gonna help you get results
and go further faster in
building your business
with online video, online
marketing, and social media.
- Yes, and I'm excited because
we did what you say, Sean,
we punched fear in the face
and we pressed record, so.
- We certainly did, especially
with those name spellings.
This is, this is just going
for it and hitting record.
So hey, we'll see you in the next episode
and thanks so much for listening.
(mellow music)